[Music]
it's the breakfast rush at the famous
cosmos in montreal
[Music]
and the diner is packed
for more than five decades cosmos has
been a gathering place for locals
creating a community of its own
so what do you like about this place the
food the people the client everything
i stop every day angie usually makes me
a bagel to go in the morning as a
teenager david minikuchi would come to
cosmos after school to hang out with his
friends
back then it was run by the original
owner
everyone kind of comes in here every
morning checks in with angie who's been
here for 20 years and talks about their
day debates all sorts of issues you walk
in here there's always some discussion
going on
when david heard the diner was for sale
he knew he had to jump at the
opportunity
i saw cosmos come up
for sale right away i just called the
real estate agent and i put an offer for
what they were asking because it was a
place like such an attachment to very
sentimental place for me as the new
owner of cosmos david wants to expand
the business and its brand
but not with another bricks and mortar
location instead david is heading into a
whole new virtual world launching cosmos
into the metaverse
[Music]
hi kayla welcome to the metaverse
so how exciting is this we're meeting in
the metaverse is this your first
interview in the metaverse uh yeah
definitely first interview in the
metaverse pretty cool i see your avatar
yeah this is my first uh interview as
well in the metaverse
what exactly is the metaverse some are
calling it the evolution of the internet
others web 3.0
okay about to jump into the metadata i
will see you there
rn mani also known as mr who's the boss
is a youtube sensation based in the uk
with more than 10 million subscribers
he's famous for his insight into tech
this is the latest oculus quest too
including the metaverse
so i like to define it as it's not an
internet that you're looking at through
a screen
it's an internet that you're inside of
one of the coolest things in the
metaverse is this idea of being able to
feel close to people who are further
away
so
imagine a world where we're perfectly
connected you can almost snap your
fingers and feel like you're in the same
room as someone who's on a different
continent
and you'll be able to kind of see
everything from their facial expressions
to their like emotions through their
virtual avatar that's that's kind of the
promise of the metaverse
[Music]
aren says the metaverse is still in its
early stages but its potential could be
exponential
right now most of the internet is a 2d
experience
but the metaverse takes it to the next
level
making the user experience more
immersive
and interactive creating and using
avatars to explore online spaces
where people can socialize therapeutic
bro it's just this is one of them things
bro
work
[Music]
shop
or just explore
the way that i like to think about the
metaverse now is kind of how like people
thought about the internet in the 1980s
where like no one had any idea what it
was going to become no one knew there
was going to be google maps or instagram
or all the you know crazy apps that we
now use in our lives today it was very
very basic and so that's kind of where
our understanding of the metaverse is we
know it's the next stage we know we're
moving towards it very slowly very
gradually but we don't know what it's
going to become
there's a handful of online platforms
that offer metaverse experiences
some owned by companies
and others that are community driven
for example decentraland
sandbox
and horizon worlds
in these virtual worlds you can hit the
dance floor
relive your favorite sport moment
[Applause]
or even escape into the wild
all of the services that you have now
all of the websites all of the
music art business working experiences
you have on the internet now will be all
part of the metaverse in this 3d
immersive world
mark fielding is a tech writer based in
france he says a lot of companies want
to get in the metaverse during the early
stages
in march decentraland hosted its first
fashion week with brands like tommy
hilfiger
a lot of the companies that you would
expect to be utilizing these new
channels for brand building these are
the companies and these are the brands
which are transforming
the metaverse into these entertainment
centers into these communities into
these worlds of like-minded people
the metaverse is projected to be a
multi-trillion dollar revenue
opportunity and all that buzz has some
tech giants including microsoft and
facebook
investing in these virtual platforms
there is a lot of money washing around
and you have to move quickly and people
are moving very quickly investing in
these new platforms investing in these
new technologies because
time is of the essence
from now on we're going to be metaverse
first not facebook first
in october 2021 facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg announced it was changing
from a social media company to a
metaverse company
rebranding to meta and investing 10
billion dollars into its platform
if you think about like the value of
internet-based companies now
then the potential of the metaverse like
the total potential net worth of that
market is phenomenal it's almost like
every company digital or not now needs
to be a part of it
[Music]
there's a race to buy virtual land in
the metaverse with companies and users
shelling out thousands to millions of
dollars and david is one of them
he bought his virtual land at the start
of 2022 in the 3d virtual world
decentraland
and if you can tell me how much land did
you buy and how much did it cost so it
was one plot it was uh 4 700 mana which
at the time was about 15 000 canadian
15 000 canadian yeah
the metaverse doesn't fully exist yet
right and you've poured all this money
15 000 into this business
what if
what if it doesn't work any
entrepreneurial venture you've got to be
comfortable with the fact that it may
not work out and that it could be a bus
so we'll see how it plays out but i
think it might be a risk that pays off
in the end
for david the platform offers him a
chance to expand without changing the
core of the business you know i'm an
entrepreneur i want to you know grow the
business just like anybody else would
want to do but at the same time i truly
have an emotional attachment to this
place and i'll never change what we
actually do here like this establishment
here our counter our customer so the
metaverse was sort of like an
opportunity was like okay we can do
stuff without even changing stuff
[Music]
to get the cosmos authentic feel in the
metaverse david reached out to one of
his closest friends philip taba
who co-owns the montreal digital agency
field office
i'm going to load us up into
decentraland both have been loyal cosmos
customers since they were in high school
it would be amazing to have a world
where you know
if you're
stuck at home and still want to get the
feel of being at cosmos that you could
show up there
and have the same kind of conversations
that you would at cosmos
using 3d software and digital pictures
philip and the team were able to
replicate cosmos and include some
must-have features
the original
founder there's a painting of him at the
back so you know you want to honor him
and so you're trying to replicate that
in the metaverse as much as you can
we added a couple small little elements
to encourage people to come and visit
you know like we added that stage and
that kind of thing which is fun and a
second floor but you know when you walk
in
[Music]
based on the limitations we had it's as
close as we could get right now getting
an employee actually in cosmos would be
like a really cool thing especially for
people who want the real cosmos
experience
yeah the social aspect is huge and that
was the main thing that we kept saying
that we needed to make sure translated
well okay so i'm a customer and i want
to order some food from your virtual
cosmos walk me through how that process
would look like how would i order that
food so the way i see it is that you
would come in you would literally speak
to someone say hey angie she would be
able to put in an order and then it
would get linked to a ghost kitchen that
we would have set up in your cities that
order that you would place in the
metaverse would that get sent there and
then delivered through ubereats or
whatever delivery technology was out
there at the time
and for designers like philip the
metaverse opens up a whole new world of
possibilities when it comes to creating
online spaces brand building and
e-commerce
being able to walk into a store is a lot
better than
viewing a store on your phone you've
never ran into someone when you're on
your phone in a store but you can in
this you can actually speak to someone
if you walk into a store in the
metaverse so
you know not where it's at now but in
the future you could imagine the
internet being a much kind of more
interactive and fun place to be
[Music]
the metaverse is the biggest idea in
tech right now it's the concept of a
more immersive digital future
most people don't know what it is
big tech is trying to build it
others want to cash in on it
the metaverse is a futuristic idea of
online 3d spaces
that will let users socialize learn and
engage in an immersive way using virtual
reality
you can do almost anything
want a burger
even grab takeout
oh oh my gosh i forgot i just hit my tv
but with all the excitement surrounding
its potential there are also some
real-life concerns such as data
protection security
and privacy
[Music]
so the metaverse is something relatively
new a lot of folks are trying to wrap
their minds around what it is and
there's different definitions that are
out there but the simplest way of
looking at it it's a parallel virtual 3d
universe
imran ahmad is one of the leading
privacy and cyber security lawyers in
canada
how does data collection in the
metaverse differ from how our data is
currently collected on social media
platforms i think the metaverse actually
captures two types of information the
first one is all the stuff that you're
doing in the metaverse itself the
virtual world you know your transactions
your interactions and so on but the
other piece is your physiological or
biometric data
currently social media platforms
generally ask for your name location and
email address
but biometric data can be more intrusive
collecting physical and behavioral
features such as facial recognition
retinal scans and even your heart rate
biometric data is sort of the next
generation of security when we talk
about privacy the risk however is that
data that they're calling your biometric
data is then encoded into zeros and ones
so there's a code that goes along with
it if that code ever gets stolen or
taken somebody could pretend to be you
on that very unique identifier that you
now do not have the ability to change or
to correct over time could these risks
have real world implications
absolutely the they could have
significant implications in the real
world if you are able to get somebody's
biometric data coupled with real what we
call tombstone information social
insurance address date of birth and so
on there's a risk to build a profile on
that person and we're not just talking
about identity fraud we're talking about
reputational harm
imran says across canada and globally
existing laws are generally designed to
be evergreen so they could be applied to
not only new technologies but to the new
issues that may arise from them
because it's moving so fast there is no
clear governance of the metaverse and
concerns are being raised about how data
will be safeguarded
they have their own set of privacy
requirements and compliance requirements
they want participants to have it's
facebook base it's not based by
government statute or law per se
and that's the unique distinction
[Music]
facebook is not the only entity building
a metaverse platform
but the company has faced scrutiny for
data privacy issues in the past
in 2019 the tech giant was fined 5
billion dollars by the u.s federal trade
commission for alleged privacy
violations
facebook did not admit any wrongdoing as
part of the settlement
we reached out to metta facebook's
parent company and it told global news
it's taking many steps to minimize the
amount of data collected in the
metaverse and to ensure data is stored
securely and it is committed to building
privacy-centric products
experts like tech youtuber aaron maney
are raising the question about the role
of tech giants and the future of the
metaverse
should they be the ones in charge of
effectively the universe right now we
kind of have governments regulating
things right governments whose whose
main incentive is really to make the
population happy but when the new
authority effectively becomes a company
whose profit maximizing can you trust
that they're going to do all the same
jobs as well as someone who might have
your interests at heart more
and could the problems currently
plaguing social media
be made worse writer mark fielding says
these ethical issues need to be
addressed
if you're building the future you have
to study your mistakes but you have to
admit your mistakes if the people the
companies
building the metaverse don't
learn from the mistakes of our current
iterations of social media there's a big
downside to the future of the internet
to the metaverse all of the downsides we
currently experience bullying harassment
isolation anxiety cyber crime scams all
of that is and will be part of it
already there have been reports by some
users of racism hate speech and sexual
assault
various metaverse platforms have
security and safety features
including the option to report
inappropriate behavior and block other
users as well as standards participants
have to abide by
experts suggest users educate themselves
about their rights before entering these
platforms
one of my messages and part of the
reason that i'm so into making
technology videos is that i think people
need to know tech i think people need to
research they need to try to understand
this world that's kind of rapidly
approaching us because it is very easy
to get left behind you need to know how
these things work
in order to get ahead and stay ahead
despite some important issues that need
to be addressed the metaverse holds
incredible promise
it has the potential to connect people
around the world allow anyone to see
renowned works of art create jobs and
even train the next generation of
healthcare workers
i feel like a lot of what technology
aspires to do is to make us more
technically efficient and the metaverse
is the next step of that in the same way
that googling something now is far
easier than going to a library picking
out a book and scrolling to the right
page in the metaverse you could almost
learn things in an even more real way
what excites me most about the metaverse
is the potential to change the balance
of power to remove the
the zero 1.1 and to redistribute
the wealth and opportunity
the art the culture the creativity
across
the whole of society that across the
whole of civilization
the verse can do that the future of the
internet can do that
it's the potential of what the metaverse
may hold that excites diner owner david
minikuchi
he knows not everyone will understand
his decision to buy virtual land and
open the famous cosmos in the metaverse
even the diners cook angie is still
getting used to the idea i felt like the
emoji where your little brain explodes
yeah it's a lot to take in but i think
it's really cool it draws in a new
market young people are this is how they
socialize this how they do stuff so
it's cool to be out there hey you got to
uh
got to stay with the times eh you got to
keep rolling with the punches
adapt and keep moving and so it's pretty
cool
what experience do you hope your
customers will have when visiting the
virtual cosmos i want to see
if that cosmos experience is going to
translate over like are people going to
interact in the same way are they going
to interact with our employees in the
same way the customers in the same way
like are you is that social aspect going
to translate or is it going to fall flat
david wants his loyal customers to know
whether his metaverse adventure works or
not the diner they love won't change
he hopes to share cosmos with any
visitor regardless of where they are
in the real world
or online
i just want to see how it develops like
is this something that is going to
develop like the internet where all of a
sudden every single company is slowly
going to get a website is going to be
like cell phones where people slowly you
know adopted over five six seven years
and i'm curious to see the progression
of that